what film changed your life or role not
that you were in one that you saw when I
saw well first one first one was Vinnie
Barbarino I wanted to be Vinnie
Barbarino I wanted to be John Travolta
in Welcome Back Kotter I was like oh my
god how cool is that guy and then I and
that's how I found out that acting was
actually a job
he wasn't just super cool and somebody
found out and just started following him
around in his real life and that's when
I thought yeah dude I want to be like
that I want to be like that so hopefully
one day I can meet bunny Vinnie
Barbarino I think John Travolta is a
cool enough guy that if I say can I meet
Vinnie Barbarino he'll give me a little
bitty Barbara you know it's an alive
awesome but yeah it was it was
definitely seeing bad but movie wise
probably the precursor to me wanting to
be a filmmaker before I even understood
that I wanted to be a filmmaker was
seeing crimes and misdemeanors by Woody
Allen you know I just thought how cool
is this there's like two movies
happening at one time that's insane
like I've never seen that before I was a
little kid you know but still I was like
there's two movies there's like this
movie with this guy and he's in love
with this girl and the girls in love
with the douchebag and then there's a
surf movie where this guy's looking to
kill another he's trying to kill those
two movies at once it's awesome so I
love that and I think there's an old
movie 1937 it's called Stage Door and
it's a wonderful film about a bunch of
women who live in a boarding house
they're actresses they used to put
actresses and boarding homes back in the
day his stars Katharine Hepburn
it's Ginger Rogers and a dramatic
Lucille Ball before she was a redhead
it's amazing love love love love awesome
it's probably those three sort of
changed me we were talking earlier about
John Updike weird I must have been like
channeling their love for him because I
was for some reason just watching all
these videos with him yesterday I'm
doing a bunch of work and he both John
Updike and Joyce Carol Oates have both
said that a writers imagination usually
comes from being more isolated as a
child because they're alone that they
come up with these elaborate stories in
their mind that would be true in my case
okay that will be true in my case I am
the youngest of the youngest my brother
is 15 years older than me and my
sister's 11 years older than me so I was
all by myself making up stuff in my head
all the time
so yes I would agree with John Updike
he's John Updike I'd probably agree with
whatever he said we get into that that
mindset all the time and we're just
always you know I mean I spent a lot of
time alone too so it's just always
imagining things and that's how we
entertain ourselves and then we never
grow out of it I think that's why I love
writing so much so I'm all by myself
making up stories
I used to be in a place where I would be
writing all day and I get out of the
room and I'd walk around and I would be
very confused because people would be
talking but I didn't write that I didn't
write those words they're not supposed
to talk it's well sort of a just because
I get so used to creating my own world I
would walk out of my room
and somebody said hey Marcus what's up
I'll be like why are you talking I
didn't write that
I didn't write you're not supposed to
even be here like what he puts so yeah I
I would I would get completely lost in
these people and these stories I still
do I just can manage it better now so I
don't look at people weird because
people have their own brains they can
things that I didn't write it's
perfectly fine do you feel most safe
behind that computer creating that world
they were talking about to just you can
create whatever life life is one you
know sort of boring existence but then
these stories you can create is a whole
nother realm I think I know what he
Allen in deconstructing Harry you know
he he his character liked he was a
writer and he would write he couldn't
function in life but he could fix it in
fiction so I think there's definitely an
element of that to what I like to do I
don't know if it's safety that I feel I
definitely look forward to getting out
from behind the computer to make the
movies but it's definitely comfortable
it's definitely comfortable I do love
when I have the time and I'm not busy
you know directing and producing and
doing all the stuff intrinsic to that
and I can just write I do love it I do
love it it's a great place to be to just
sit and listen to music and write
you